i mean you're the extra jonas brother
you're part of the jonas brother family
it was a jonas brothers weekend
extravaganza here in las vegas they were
literally everywhere from kicking off
their summer residency to opening their
family restaurant we were there to
capture it all take a look
the jonas brothers kicked off their live
in vegas residency this weekend at park
mgm to be here be surrounded by so many
amazing fans and to see them to come out
to support our family's restaurant we're
so proud of our parents and it's a
family affair family affairs and
southern hospitality that's what the
nelly's southern kitchen grand opening
was all about at mgm it's a pleasure i
mean i worked in the kitchen for two
years it's just it's so amazing to get
to see what my dad has accomplished what
the family's accomplished this is just
such a testament to like the family what
we've worked through to get here we're
so proud among those who are proud are
kevin and denise jonas the parents of
the jonas brothers how excited are you
for the boys kicking off that residency
last night
[Applause]
always incredible and it never gets old
we have the most supportive parents in
the world
and so it's you know really meaningful
for us to be able to come out here
literally hours before we go on stage to
have a bite to eat celebrate them and
this new venture here at mgm
and uh you know we love the food i'm
sure everyone else is going to it's it's
a really special night the joe bros made
it a special night for everyone
including this lucky fan my parents
asked me if i wanted a birthday party or
if i wanted a trip and i said i want to
see the jonas brothers in vegas
and now i'm here at the red carpet
seeing them and i got an autographed
photo which is like the best thing ever
oh my gosh can you hold it up to the
camera so we can get it oh my gosh
fans from all over gather to support the
jonas family and if you get the chance
to stop by nellie's here are what kevin
joe and nick recommend you try i had the
steak the other night which is new on
the menu it's fantastic but the biscuits
are phenomenal
crunch cap chicken what very good yeah
it's incredible it's all good you enjoy
everything gotta try it all right
that is